good morning everyone hello believe
nation happy monday welcome to gratitude
journal live stream number 31 it's the
last one that i'm going to be doing live
on this channel and it's been fun it's
been a good that's a full month 31 days
so what we do those you guys who might
be new is i share three things that were
before I share mine you guys share yours
in a live chat share it down below in
the comments afterwards because when you
are grateful for what you have you'll be
a happier entrepreneur and we need happy
entrepreneurs go and do amazing things
to make the world a better place if you
look at any study pneus at any study
pneus your get any study unhappiness any
studying happiness gratitude is always
always always on the list of the things
that lead to happiness and so I want you
guys to be happy I do this with my team
and we brought it to youtube so you guys
could benefit and be involved as well
and it's just super important and the
second part is that you do it daily it's
like brushing your teeth you gotta do it
daily brushing your teeth for your mind
flossing your mind and then you ask
yourself why why is this important to me
why are these three things important
just that little bit of self-reflection
makes it really really really big
difference so I me out with mine you
guys in live chat leave yours let's do
it for me my first one is I'm really I'm
really grateful that I'm trying new
things out to try new things even this
like the live channel is something new
that I'm testing right and on that live
channel we're gonna have most of the
live broadcast to grab two journals most
of the interviews that I do for the
channel going to be over there for
people who really want to be a part of
the live community and I hope it works
it may not work right you don't know you
don't know until you try so for all
those ideas you have that you want to
try you know this could be the biggest
backfire of my youtube career could be
the greatest thing ever I don't know I
gotta try and so just having that
mindset of being willing to try
something that that may not work has
helped me a lot and it doesn't always
work
get a lot of things don't work at a less
bill quick um but you don't know till
you try and then you keep trying you're
going to hit on a couple things that do
end up being amazing um number 2 i'm
grateful this is maybe more med I'm just
I'm just grateful for my life I woke up
this morning a little early unusual Nina
had an early morning meeting so she was
out the door super early i usually wake
up to my room but going off in this
morning i woke up earlier before it went
off it was still dark outside and it was
just just me in my place and it was
super calm and i got to see the sunrise
come up and you know clean up a little
bit and just I don't know I'm not used
to having that quiet morning time by
myself and it was nice and relaxing and
I was grateful for that moment and
number 3 i'm grateful that i'm back on
schedule the past couple mondays have
been passed three mondays have been off
for me off from my usual work schedule
because i was out recording the audio
book for two of them and then we had
canadian thanksgiving as well and so I
packed so much into my days that when I
miss a day is why I hate to travel you
know I'm super selective with the
speaking that I do because if I'm out
for three or four or five days I just
lose so much work I don't get enough
done this the amount that I pack into my
schedule is so condensed that when I
can't have that day just one day I fall
behind a lot of stuff and so the past
week mondays have been rough falling
behind on a lot of stuff that needs to
get done and and it was great right like
get to the audiobook I so pumped about
that and it's that joy and that
experience of doing it and I don't
regret it at all and i'm also not super
good will be back on schedule feels so
good to have my usual monday lined up so
I'm excited for that so those are my
three we have six minutes I'm going to
do some shout outs on the channel see
you guys are grateful for leave it in
the live chat there on the side and
we're going to start going through them
first up Marvel grateful for having
water and gas back on the whole town was
cut off due to some infrastructure
related work for
around five hours that sucks that sucks
things you take for granted every single
day that's true what's worse and losing
gas and power those losing internet I
would rather lose gas and water than
lose internet but I'm glad it's all back
for you Zeno we've before number one by
pillow it's very nice and soft I like it
two ideas that I can hopefully no I will
turn into something special I love that
socks for keeping my feet warm awesome
what else we got Junior Oh for you did a
fourth one grateful for a new day that's
not always a case but today I am I love
it J reyez thankful for my morning
meditation for allows no thank you for
my morning meditation which allows
relief clarity and alignment for Google
and all the free services in the world
for higher ground a stylish technical
clothes store especially in the winter
higher ground I feel like I know it but
maybe I don't and J reyez thankful for
peeps who made both experiments like
Evan testing this new live stream only
channel let's check it out see how it
goes will link it up it should be ready
length in description if you guys want
to join me tomorrow for the live stream
it's going to be there for the gratitude
journal new future bitter a good morning
in morning Justin how you doing man
Prabhu hey guys time hello push trim
hello m pancake when you gonna do Seth
MacFarlane hey leave it in the comments
not here because my team will pick this
up not the live comments with the
regular comments gfs construction
morning Deborah hello Antoine good
morning all these mornings Craig morning
Deborah study pneus hahaha I don't I'm
not following that one but I love it klb
and I was looking for the link all
morning Marcus good morning dirt by
grateful for graduate dirtbag squad is
grateful for graduating college with a
bachelor's degree in business yesterday
I love that man clapping that up good
job dirtbag skills we retain that but
I'm happy for you que el bien buen dia
grupo Valentin hello from Russia lon
nikka good morning je je NY last as I
said at the
pop we're gonna be doing it on the new
live channel so tomorrow you can join me
in the link below subscribe to that
channel and we'll be doing all the life
gravity journals there as well as a lot
of the interviews for the channel what
else breathe fitness hey gratitude
people Henry Ford likes turtles i right
vehicle for turtles I love turtles you
know turtles are whenever I go to uh to
the Caribbean my goal is always to swim
with turtles I've never been able to do
it we go to like turtle bay in all these
places were you supposed to be able to
swim with turtles and I've never been
able to swim with trip I never see them
there I see them in the aquariums but
I've never swam it's one of us on my
bucket list swim with a turtle so I'm
good with four turtles saini good
morning Evan one thankful for you and
all my YouTube mentors that keep me
motivated and inspired I love that
grateful for fall and the changes of
seasons a hundred percent we went for a
beautiful fall walk for the past two
weekends took some great pictures J
reyez hashtag mine floss Aviv hey Evan
kale bien I'm grateful for the chocolate
delights provided to us when we went to
the Loews Portofino Bay Hotel very cool
breathe fitness TV travel this week work
is awesome you are all awesome health is
awesome happiness is awesome awesome is
awesome that's love breathe fitness TV
is showing some love manju not his
people for the universe Kail being given
for my dog Chloe for always getting me
in the morning and showing me love it's
amazing how dogs do that right like no
matter how bout it that you've had feels
like dogs don't have bad days they're
always happy you can always count on the
dog coming home and being happy and
wanted to play Melissa hello good
morning beliefs nación Zeno hey everyone
jf construction gfs bunk know what that
means sani grateful for the internet
under hundred percent Antoine grateful
for my daily workout just did it and I'm
on fire I love it and want me to I just
did I just got this trampoline and I did
20 minutes of jumping on the trampoline
just pretty good 20 minutes of jumping
them into the shower and then on with
you guys
I'm on hi sir Bishop our ass Walker good
morning everyone he'll be in a grateful
for little packages of coffee because
they come to the rescue when there isn't
any coffee left in the cabinet I love it
sadiq a Sarah good morning I'm so
grateful for one knowing of beautiful
mountain trails to run very cool to
finally having money to visit family
congrats on that and three a strong back
due to my exercises super cool i love
this what else jf construction JSI keep
saying jf jf asked construction gave of
being able to leave this buck whack all
right I don't know what that's all about
oh wow just skip the bunch sorry guys I
missed a whole bunch of them here
Antoine 20 minutes awesome sherry I'm
with much love chocolate David Brad I'm
good for the beach the place where I can
empty my mind for a few minutes and just
relax on sunday so i can get ready for
my week ahead love that guys listen it's
nine ten we're gonna hop on to the
twitch livestream to answer your
business questions while Rishi Cup TV j
reyez are all there playing league of
legends hopefully i'll see you there if
not have an amazing day again tomorrow
if you want to join us it's on the new
channel the live channel hopefully I'll
see you there to continue in our
tradition of gratitude journals in the
morning at nine a.m. eastern thank you
guys as amazing diego and crush it
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and i'll see you soon